[BACKGROUND VOICES]
Bruce Sewell >> Hi, Pablo. Hi, YouTube viewers.
AH-my name's Bruce Sewell. I'm with Intel.
Um-I'm the Chief Legal Counsel and I'm also
responsible for corporate social responsibility.
I think it's a great question. Um-the difference,
I think, though, between CEOs and doctors
and lawyers is that doctors and lawyers are
regulated by the state. They have to pass
a licensing exam in order to be qualified
to practice. And as a result the state has
sort of a heightened interest in making sure
that they have certain levels of competence
and that they follow certain standards of
behaviors. I'd be a bit uncomfortable about
trying to superimpose some sort of regulatory
structure on CEOs in general. I think because
it's likely to have sort of an in-inhibiting
effect on the entrepreneurship that we want
to encourage among the CEOs.
But having said that, certainly CEOs are no
less in need of a code of responsibility or
of a code of ethics than are lawyers or doctors.
So, what I'd like to see is some sort of cross-functional-perhaps
a comprehensive-attempt to define a code of
conduct and then make the adoption of that
code and the adherence to that code a matter
of voluntary participation. But it should
be transparent. So a CEO who signs up to this
that fact should be known to the shareholders
and to the Board of Directors. A CEO who chooses
not to sign up to this, that fact should also
be known and could be taken into account when
the shareholders or when the directors are
considering that CEO's performance and considering
that CEO for, perhaps, continuation of employment.
So that's what I'd like to say.